c'est une poignée de main dans l'espace
un geste symbolique entre un soviétique
un américain une première ce 17 juillet
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les vols conjoints russo
américains sont communs mais ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
il faut attendre le début des années
soixante dix pour que les deux grandes
puissances met la guerre froide entre
parenthèses c'est la détente
nixon et brejnev se rencontrent un
accord est signé pour une accolade dans
l'espace commence alors une grande
opération de communication en 73 au
salon de l'aéronautique au bourget que
soit notre soviétique et astronaute
américain tient un stand commun et font
langue commune pour que apollo et soyuz
s'accouplent un système d'amarrage
universel et conçu la grande scène de la
réconciliation se poursuit ici au centre
d'entraînement de baïkonour au
kazakhstan soviétiques et américains
forme des pères très souriante
philippe chicaud le pilote de feu ioset
conversant avec bin astronautes d'apollo
et skylab
et puis léonov le fameux pied dont de
l'espace discutant avec ces deux zones
ils rencontreront le 17 juillet même la
poignée de main a été répété devant les
caméras et comme les membres de chaque
équipage par les deux langues
un protocole très diplomatique a été
instauré histoire d'éviter tout incident
pendant toute la mission les cosmonautes
russes parleront anglais lorsqu ils
s'adresseront à leurs collègues
américains et ceux ci leur répondre
en russe cela évitera l'utilisation de
mots compliqués que certains pourraient
ne pas qu'on le 15 juillet les deux
vaisseaux d'école de leurs bases
respectives
et deux jours plus tard c'est la
rencontre l'arrimage est réussi la
poignée de main aussi et durant deux
jours soviétiques et américains
partageront leurs maigres repas et bien
sûr livreront des messages sur la
coopération internationale et la paix
dans le monde
[Musique]
quatre ans plus tard l'urss envahit
l'afghanistan khl c'est la fin de la
détente et il faudra attendre le
lancement du programme iss
la station spatiale internationale pour
voir
russes et américains partagent et de
nouveau des concerts dans l'espace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]